did you see the game yesterday clippers
against uh
are you a basketball guy or not really
clubs played the sons last night
mo more baseball football more baseball
a bunch of guys were wearing masks
apparently this mask thing is coming
back to la la
urges everyone to start wearing masks
again
indoors as delta variant spreads this is
an la time
story which is not in there this just
came out more than three in five
californians have gotten at least one
vaccine dose to date but fewer than half
are truly vaccinated
fully vaccinated according to the data
from u.s sensor
centers for disease and control and
prevention
california has won the nation's highest
vaccination rates and that has many
experts confident that the delta strain
won't cause the kind of kova 19
surges seen over the last year i was
watching the clippers game
and i'm seeing uh who's the center for
the clips who's the big guy
zubac who's got a bit of an injury he's
got this mask on
on the sidelines it was the biggest mask
i've ever seen i'm looking at all the
fans
fans don't have any masks yeah the
clippers have masks on and players are
not putting masks i get a message on
instagram saying you know california is
back on putting masks on what do you
think about this mask situation right
now in california
it's just california to be specific
they've obviously
overreacted to some of this i mean you
have a state like florida which
did not have mass mandates and you come
here and kind of do what you want to do
california no difference in rates by the
way of disease
right well yeah that's true then the
well new york is obviously way worse
than california from what i understand
they don't even put masks on they put
like scarves on desks on you know
it's just you know different strokes for
different folks at the end of the day
it's so weird because you go to the
games that
people in the crowd doesn't wear a mask
but then uh when you're playing you
don't have to wear a mask when you go to
the bench you put on the mask
and then some people do the old i i just
put it over my mouth but not over my
nose and some people keep it under their
neck
and then some people like have worn the
same mask for the last 12 months they
haven't replaced the mask
the mask clearly is like old and rotten
and dirty there's just no uniformity to
the mask thing there's only just one
visual that makes sense to me
it's only one visual and it's the same
it was a year and a half ago as it is
today okay when i see
tyron liu wearing a mask while he's
doing an interview with espn
unzoom by himself i'm telling you that's
like we're in a condom going to sleep
with no one to have sex with
like you just have a condom on for no
reason i mean is it just
what are you doing with that there's no
it makes no longer these are smart
people like okay i'm looking at the zoom
how the hell can i get the virus from
you
on the zoom or the people driving in
their car yeah
are those i take pictures of i mean i
like to take pictures with those guys
and selfies because
it's a it's a league of their own that's
what they've got going on that's where
like
it's like wearing a seat belt when
you're walking yeah makes no sense no
you got you
you're parked okay on a phone call
you're you're making a phone call with
two somebody and you put your seat belt
down
let me put my sleep on before we talk on
the phone like there's certain logic
that just makes
zero sense these are people you would
hope these are people you would
you know make fun of but today it's seen
as responsible
you both made points that made me think
about a story that you were talking
about too and that's what's going on
with teaching the fa
faa uh individuals tsa individuals
rather
more self-defense and i think this is a
result of since january 1st has been 3
000 incidents of unruly passengers but
when you look into it it's all
mass compliance and it's frustrating
because i fly a lot
there's no uniformity as you said some
flight attendants are pretty reasonable
about it some it's like
boy it is like really super difficult
dictatorship
it's like they finally got this power
and they could be mean and nasty and
whatever and
you know look i know it's not an easy
job for them okay so i respect that
but why don't you just make it so that
if you're vaccinated get a vaccine right
if you're vaccinated why do you need to
wear a mask
or why do you need to prove it you want
to take a risk on your own take a risk
on your own some people as you said have
sex without protection right so
they take their risks they know what
they're doing oh that's that's fine if
you're going to have to take the risk of
having sex without protection
my worry is people that don't have a sex
partner who are wearing condoms
that's my word i'm not worried about
those guys that's to each his own that's
a libertarian
practicing safe sex it's very sad
understand that part that's really
the key word practicing yeah so um so i
think i think that when you when you
look at it you would say look
if you have if you have a concern wear
mask
yeah well i think that's what people are
doing they keep moving the goal posts
you wear a mask you don't wear a mask if
it's up to you individual liberties
you're on a plane you don't you have to
wear a mask but when you take a sip of
the water
you get to take the mask off and if
you're eating a snack you can in between
how many times have people have went to
eat something and then boom your mask is
on boom now i got pasta on my face by
the way
did you hear what uh uh what's his name
what uh uh uh what what's the place we
always talk about kai
uh um the country no the country that is
low regulation entrepreneurs are living
there
singapore singapore you know what
singapore said with covet
moving f have we seen this data or no
pull up singapore covet uh
flu just type in singapore covid
flew just put covet flu okay let me see
if it shows up
i was just about to give you credit for
spelling things right
no no never go back to the same role
looks to live virus okay right there go
to
uh south china morning post yeah right
there click on that
uh singapore preparing to live with
endemic covert 19
as residents grow battle weary or
pandemic so what
what singapore is now doing is the
following singapore is officially
treating the covid
okay as flu meaning it's no longer is a
big deal look go back to your life do
what you were doing
no longer the over regulatory stuff that
they're going to anyways i mean you see
what's going on in florida we ended up
in florida you see what's going on in
texas
texas was a great place to be while you
were doing covet business didn't take a
massive hit
you saw what happened a couple of these
states and california is apparently
still
going back to what it was before even
after all the people got the
vaccinations it's also easy
to do the monday morning quarterback
thing with covid when this first
happened
and i'm not trying to be political or
anything like that no one ever seen
anything like this in the last hundred
years so you don't know
the severity of it should we wear a
match should we social justice should we
not we didn't have a vaccine a year ago
the vaccine came out towards the
beginning of the year now people are
getting vaccinated so
the story keeps evolving the story keeps
changing fauci said you don't need to
wear a mask and you need to wear a mask
it's i think people the problem here in
america is that it got so politicized
that if you
if you're a social distancing fan and
you believe in mass that means you're a
democrat
but if you're not then you're a
republican and a republican you don't
wear the madison
it's just such a moving situation
there's moving targets that
this is where it just comes down to
individual consistency patrick by the
way just to go back for a second
my son jake was a really big fan of
yours and uh he
ran the numbers for me he said that home
we were looking at for 500 a little less
than 500 thousand dollars
if you paid 60 000 over asking price it
would take you 25 months to break even
so that might be a bit you might want to
take you know it would take you 25
months
in 25 months that home would be worth
560. now
i mean maybe you go either way on it but
if you said i'm going to be there for 10
years it's not a bad gig
and remember it might take you two or
three months to close so you reduce that
a little bit two months
yeah yeah you can do the math but that's
how people should be
thinking by the way by the way how many
the question becomes how many realtors
are selling the way you just sold right
now because
by the way you don't benefit from
anything you don't sell loans you don't
do
you don't sell homes so it's not like we
provide the tools like this for realtors
it's a different story but you're not
selling no i'm not selling so you're not
selling a house you don't have a house
on a market
you say come and look at this 10 million
house maybe you're representing dianne
feinstein's house in lake tahoe by the
way
you're not though right so so the point
is the point is
today's realtor imagine a realtor today
saying adam how long you're going to
live in this house
10 years then don't worry about it this
500 000 house is going to be 560 in two
years you're fine buy the house make an
offer 60 000
more think about the way the realtor has
to sell the clients today patrick it's a
different sale
i think in life what we want to try and
do is if we think linearly
right one two three four five yeah and
we grow that way versus exponentially
what we
need to do is if you can find points of
friction all over if you remove a point
of friction like this
you will grow exponentially it's not
just in is this problems like this all
over
this is a big point of friction you come
up with a solution your business grows
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye